we've got to get to some breaking news
is just coming in where buckingham
palace says queen elizabeth's doctors
are quote concerned for her majesty's
health the 96 year old monarch is at her
residence in scotland where she canceled
a virtual meeting with royal officials
yesterday let's go now to charlie
daggett in london for the latest on the
story charlie good morning this does
sound very concerning
it is concerning gail this is the
statement we got from the palace moments
ago
following further evaluations this
morning the queen's doctors are
concerned for her majesty's health and
have recommended that she remain under
medical supervision the queen remains
comfortable and at balmoral
that is her summer residence where she's
been for the past few months now we
understand
her family members have been informed
prince william is headed to balmoral
according to the palace prince charles
and camilla also headed there uh harry
and megan are
in the uk they were scheduled to
appear at an event in london tonight
we're not sure what their plans are uh
considering the situation now the the
last time we saw the queen was on
tuesday she was meeting with the new
prime minister liz truss
the new prime minister made a statement
in commons
earlier saying my thoughts and the
thoughts of people across the united
kingdom are with her majesty the queen
and her family at this time as you said
the 96 year old has been dogged by
medical problems since october she is
now under medical supervision
all right charlie daggett of course
we'll monitor we've seen the queen rally
before let's hope everything turns out
okay again
thank you very much charlie dagetta
reporting from london